-This feels like a rehearsal.
-Yeah. But if anything's good,
we'll keep it.
-Great.
-Because you're actually --
You are doing a show every night
in a theater with human beings.
-I am. And, by the way,
is everybody here vaccinated?
-Yeah.
-Not me. Let me tell you why.
[ Laughter ]
Seth, there's a lot of
information out there.
I felt like tonight's the night
I'm going to right
a lot of wrongs.
Go ahead.
-How is it doing shows
for people wearing masks?
-I thought it would bother me,
and then I remembered that
I got my start in comedy
doing stand-up
at "Eyes Wide Shut"-style
sex parties.
-Oh, right, I forgot about that.
So it was almost all masks.
-Yeah. That was all masks.
-And you were like an opener,
right?
You'd come on
before the sex started?
-I would kind of
get them in the mood.
Couple sex jokes.
-'Cause I've always heard
the worst thing
was, like, comedians in the '70s
would open for,
like, rock acts a lot,
like before concerts.
-Edgar Winter.
But yeah, they didn't do "Eyes
Wide Shut"-style sex parties.
[ Laughter ]
-I feel like the stakes there --
'Cause I feel like people
are like, "Let's get this guy
off stage."
-And to all of my old friends
watching, fidelio.
[ Laughter ]
Fidelio.
-Is that your safe word?
-No, fidelio is the password
that Tom Cruise says
to get into the party.
-Really?
-And all the freaks
in the studio
who laughed at that
have watched the movie
multiple times.
[ Laughter ]
And now they know.
-But just that part.
-Yeah, that's all.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hey, so, "3 Mics," one of
the best stand-up specials
of the last I'm going to say
20 years.
-Damn!
-One of the mikes was about
emotional stuff,
and this show strikes me
as an extension of that.
-It is somewhat of an extension.
It's less delineated.
Like, "3 Mics" was like
I'm gonna be funny
and everybody would be like,
"Alright, he's gonna be funny."
And then I'd be like,
"Alright, I'm gonna be sad."
And everybody would be sad
and then I'd do one-liners
and they'd be whatever they are
for the one-liners.
This is more interwoven.
It's a bit like I start off kind
of like a glib comedian, right?
And slowly but surely I show
that I'm a human boy inside.
[ Laughter ]
-You are a human boy inside.
One of the things
you talk about --
and you and I are the same age.
We're both comedians.
One difference between us
is I am married,
I have children.
-Income.
[ Laughter ]
-Which I really asked not to
make tonight about but...
But you --
-Seriously, what do you make?
[ Laughter ]
-You know who actually asked me
that once?
-This is my favorite story
and I think about him
every time I say it --
every time I see him.
Tell the story.
-I did a talk show.
There was someone who had
a short-lived talk show.
I was a guest on it, and they,
on air, asked me
how much I make.
And that person was...?
-John McEnroe.
[ Laughter ]
The weirdest part is that
John McEnroe had a talk show.
-He did.
-Yeah.
-And it was filmed in Secaucus.
I had to go to New Jersey.
-Yeah. Did you know
you were doing a talk show
or you just got kidnapped?
[ Laughter ]
-A guy in a van said,
"You like tennis?"
[ Laughter ]
-"Who doesn't like tennis? Hey!"
-So, someone drew you.
-I was on Joe Rogan's podcast,
which never makes the news.
He does a small podcast.
-He does a small podcast, yeah.
-So I was on
Joe Rogan's podcast.
Apparently there's a guy
who draws the guest
while they're on, right?
-Yeah.
-So this is a --
He made a drawing of me.
-Uh-huh.
-And I thought it was so stupid.
Will you show the drawing,
please?
-I'm going to start
by showing the drawing.
I want to cover up --
Alright, that's the drawing.
-I mean, you want to
talk about ghoulish.
-Yeah, that's not -- I really
like the poster for your show.
I think it shows
how you're a handsome person.
This is deeply unfair.
-This is the opposite.
This is how I feel.
[ Laughter ]
-Aww.
That's what you can see
in the show, stuff like this.
-I feel like
you'll blow this up.
We're shooting in 4K.
Do a little tighter.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright. So wait.
Now tell me how you --
-I was like, "You know what?
That's a bad picture, but I'd be
a sucker not to pose like that
on my driver's license photo."
-So you went and posed for
your driver's license photo
hoping to emulate that.
-To capture what it was.
And I think I did it.
Wow.
[ Laughter ]
Wow!
-I mean, it is --
there's no way --
There's no way,
if a cop asks for your license
and you give him that,
you get away with a warning.
-I think you're getting away
with everything or nothing.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You talk about dating models.
-I guess I've dated
a few models.
-Yeah.
-You know, Seth, ultimately
what I learned was
that dating a model
is like owning a dune buggy.
And dating a model is
like owning a dune buggy
because at the beach it's great,
but every everywhere else,
you're like, "I shouldn't have
brought you here."
[ Laughter ]
Guys, that's probably
the best joke in my show.
-And you gave it away.
-And I gave it away for $460.
[ Laughter ]
-Before taxes.
-Before your agent took a bite.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
And you make the same, right?
$467?
-Yeah, but my agents don't
commission Tuesdays.
So I make a little bit more.
-Oh, that's really cool.
-Hey, so, you kind of
have a dune buggy.
-This is a lot of --
-This is the dumbest thing
I've ever seen.
-Okay, so, I -- Sometimes I'll
work with comedians on their --
I directed your Netflix special,
"Lobby Baby," of course.
Would have gotten
a round of applause.
-Yeah, would've I think
on a normal day.
-I think at least
a hearty six-seconder
if not a standing ovation.
-Yeah.
The crew, on the other hand.
-The crew, on the other hand.
-Could not move a muscle.
-They are checking
their phones right now.
[ Laughter ]
And so I will -- So, I helped
Chris Rock on his last Netflix,
and he gave me money, right?
A nice, fine amount of money,
right?
And then -- $467.
And then his assistant
kept calling me,
"when are you going to be home,
when are you going to be home,
when are you going to be home."
I'm like,
"Something good's coming."
Didn't know what
it was going to be.
And I go outside and he got me
this, like, Batmobile thing.
It's a three-wheel motorcycle,
and the guy's like,
"Alright, sign for it."
And I go, "I don't want it."
[ Laughter ]
And he's like, "No, but you got
to sign for it."
I'm like,
"No. I'm not taking it."
And he's like, "I'll bring it
into your garage."
I go, "If it goes into my
garage, I'll never get rid of it
so I will not sign for it."
And the guy thought
I was doing a bit.
And then eventually I just said,
"Hey, man,
I'm never taking this.
What do we do?"
So the guy is like,
"We'll sell it on layaway
at the dealership."
So I'm like,
"I'm going to make $27,000
off this goofy-ass motorcycle."
This is such a goofy motorcycle,
there is a button
that says "traction."
So I got to hit
a button for traction? Okay.
So I call the car dealership
a few weeks later,
and they're giving me
the runaround.
And eventually he goes,
"Oh, they didn't tell you?
They gave it to somebody else."
So I think what Rock did
was I don't -- I may be wrong,
but I believe he gave it to
the roast master general
Jeff Ross as a gift.
-So keep an eye out if you see
one of those three-wheelers.
-Jeff used it.
It found a good home.
-Alright.
-And Rock goes, "Well, no,
I just thought --"
I go, "Why would you get me
a motorcycle?"
He's like, "I don't know.
I just thought like --"
Jay Leno goes out with him
sometimes.
I'm like, "So you think
what would Neal want?
Well, what does Jay Leno want?"
[ Laughter ]
-I'd like to close,
as we always do,
with a photo that was taken
of us back in the day.
-This was 2005.
-2005, you and I went out
a fair amount.
We went out to social occasions
where people danced on
banquettes
and drank Dutch beer,
as I'm doing in this photo.
And you feel like this photo --
-This is why you're married
and I'm doing a show
called "Unacceptable"
at the Cherry Lane Theatre,
unacceptableshow.com.
This is the difference
between Seth and Neal,
why Seth is married
and Neal is still single.
-Two gentlemen of the same age
with similar faces.
-We're gonna start
tight on Seth.
And then go to Seth.
And then wow.
[ Laughter ]
Neal's got that thousand-yard
stare, thinking of
"Eyes Wide Shut"-style
sex parties gone awry.
[ Laughter ]
-Buddy, it's always great
to have you here.
-Buddy, I love you.
-I love you too.
-I'm so happy that I get to
touch your shoulder.
-Congrats on the show.
The show is great.
I'm really happy you're doing it
and that you're going to be
in the city till November.
Neal Brennan, "Unacceptable."
It's playing at the Cherry Lane
through November 21st.